hello and welcome everyone to our
network security class my name is Dan
Bonin I'm a professor of computer
science here at Stanford University and
I'm really excited and looking forward
to tell you everything about network
security so in this course you're going
to learn a number of topics in network
security we're going to focus about
first of all how the internet works how
Internet protocols operates and then
we're going to look at various security
problems with these internet protocols
you're going to learn about how to
deploy network defense tools and
basically how to manage a network so
that it's harder to compromise then
we're going to switch gears and talk
about a specific type of attack called a
denial of service attack and there are
many many types of attacks that come
under the guise of denial of service
we're going to tell you how those
attacks work and we're going to teach
you how to defend against those attacks
and finally we'll talk about the TLS
protocol which is probably the most
widely used security protocol on the
Internet